ich bin major Andreas Hofer ich bin der
logistik-chef hier in unserem Basislager
in harte wir sind gerade auf dem
Lagerplatz hier wird die gesamte
Verpflegung und auch das Wasser gelagert
dass wir über den Zeitraum des Einsatzes
benötigen werden rundherum angebracht
unsere darstellte wo jeweils 10 Personen
mächtigen können und sich nach dem
Einsatzen einsetzen erholen können diese
werden versorgt durch Generatoren wo wir
dann Licht und Strom bekommen und auch
Heizgeräte wo wir eine
Wohlfühltemperatur von 20 Grad erreichen
im Hintergrund sind noch zwei PCs und
gerade am Aufbau nicht sichtbar unser
Duschcontainer wo wir uns dann auch nach
dem Einsetzen eine wohlverdiente Dusche
genehmigen können somit sind wir für den
gesamten Zeitraum in unserem Einsatzraum
autark hier eingerichtet und es geht uns
damit sehr gut